desesperados por una pinta este panorama
en el centro londinense parece en el
2019 pero es la última imagen masiva en
un pub antes de un nuevo confinamiento
es como cuando te subes al metro y te
dice cuidado con las puertas que se
cierran y tienes que entrar parece la
víspera de año nuevo hay esa atmósfera
de noche viene el aire horas antes del
cierre los distritos comerciales de la
ciudad también estaban abarrotados de
personas que buscaban cierta terapia en
las compras siguiendo a gales e irlanda
del norte reino unido desde los últimos
de una serie de naciones europeas en
confinar por segunda vez tras la
reclusión de marzo
por ello los pubs y restaurantes así
como las tiendas no esenciales cerrarán
durante un mes mientras que a los
ciudadanos se les ha pedido teletrabajar
aún cuando los centros educativos
seguirán abiertos no me importa mucho
porque hemos hecho muchas compras y con
suerte será solo por cuatro semanas
obviamente es molesto queremos hacer
planes pero así es como funciona reino
unido tiene el número más alto de
muertes por commit 19 en europa
tras las casi 500 del miércoles el país
supera ya los 48 mil fallecimientos pese
a estas cifras el gobierno británico
insiste que el confinamiento expira el 2
de diciembre
entonces espero seremos capaces de hacer
que este país vuelva a funcionar de que
negocios y tiendas vuelvan a abrir para
el periodo de navidad pero eso depende
de que todos aportemos ahora
se espera que el banco de inglaterra
inyecta 100.000 millones de libras extra
a las empresas para ayudarlas a
enfrentar este encierro